visiblement attendu par Vladimir Poutine
le président turc rejoint son homologue
russe avant un entretien entre les deux
dirigeants
une poignée de mains à l'image de la
relation entre Vladimir Poutine
paradoxalement renforcé depuis le début
de la guerre en Ukraine alors que les
Occidentaux peinent à négocier avec le
président russe redchep taiper Doan
c'est lui imposé comme le médiateur du
conflit avec les Nations Unies en
juillet il a notamment aidé à conclure
un accord entre Moscou et Kiev pour
relancer les exportations ukrainiennes
de céréales il y a moins d'un mois le
président turc annonçait aussi que 200
prisonniers de guerre avaient été
échangés entre qui avait Moscou depuis
le début de la guerre en Ukraine redchep
a hyperdoan se targue de mener une
politique équilibrée d'un côté il offre
son soutien moral et militaire à Kiev de
l'autre il ménage la Russie ainsi la
Turquie ne s'est pas jointes aux
sanctions occidentales contre Moscou
alors qu'elle est membre de l'OTAN
il faut dire que le président turc fait
face à une situation économique
difficile avec des élections prévues en
juin il cherche donc à préserver les
échanges commerciaux avec Moscou
devenu incontournable sur le dossier
ukrainien redchep à n’espère désormais
amener les présidents russes et
ukrainiens à se rencontrer pour des
pourparler de paix
ce